[Music]
I'm assuming you're not with anyone
never see you with
[Music]
anyone this see moment
dab
yeah they died just before I was
12 I'm trying to write about them at the
moment how's it
going
strangely my understanding is correct me
if I'm wrong but but the book is kind of
more of a horror story I thought about
trying to do it as a more traditional
ghost story and then it just didn't seem
to work for me but the more that I read
the novel and the more I worked I
realized the novel felt very personal to
tet Yamada I don't know if it was
actually but it felt it and I thought
that was the power of it so for me it
was like okay I need to do the same
thing I'm going to ground it in my
reality reality of my own life and
aspects of my own life as a way to make
it feel really really specific and
grounded because it's such a you know
out there story essentially and then
slowly the adaptation kind of took shape
and the the supernal elements of It kind
of slipped away and it sort of existed
in this kind of slightly different Lial
subconscious metaphysical space that it
ended up being in Andrew how did the
project find its way to you and and What
attracted you to playing Adam I was
totally Blown Away by the script when I
first read it and I just felt that the
character was somebody that I really
recognized and I thought it was so
cinematic what he was going through
somebody who is dealing with stuff that
is in one way very brutal but mostly um
is dealing with something that uh uh
just seemed just seemed very
recognizable to me which is as sort of
the um accidental cruelty of families
and how you you're desperate for your
your family particularly your parents to
see you um and even if they are
brutalizing and uh they hurt your
feelings you just want them to to love
you and um I just thought I just thought
the idea of going back into um uh
childhood so to speak uh or to at least
a childishness was was really beautiful
and to be able to do that alongside a
sort of beautiful love story just is an
incredible opportunity and Jamie I'm
imagining there you probably never
imagined a world in which you'd play
Andrew Scott's father opposite him you
know like maybe sure if the flashbacks
or something like that but getting to
share scenes with him as your son how
how surreal and wonderful was that I
don't think about any like difference in
terms I I really genuinely didn't in
terms of age or whatever experience or
anything like that that was like the
last thing I was really thinking about
it was more about kind of slight anxiety
about this whole thing like is this
actually going to come together in the
way that we wanted to the way that we
believe it could it took about two hours
of filming and then heg came up to me
and CLA and he was like
you're as Mom and you're as Dad and and
that was it wow and it was just never
talked about again it was just never
something that really we just we just
had to reach out to him with love that
was what that was the objective he said
it's incredibly easy there was no there
was no point at any point for any of us
that we thought oh this is really weird
you know it's something that we've been
talking about a lot but you know because
a lot of my work is in the theater and
you know in the theater we do a lot of
pretending to be 17 different types of
people in the audience accept it I was
terrified but Lally it was you know cuz
the film does not work if you just find
it stupid the film is just a disaster uh
but like within like yeah the first
couple of hours of doing the I was like
it just totally works but then I've
thought about it a lot since and I do
think it's when we think of our parents
when we think of anybody close to us we
often think of them as we did when we
were younger anyway even if your parents
are still alive you don't think of them
as an old person necessarily you think
of them as when they were younger so I
think you know we time travel all the
time in our heads probably my favorite
scene in the movie is the one between
the two of you where you AP I say you
I'm sorry Adam's father apologizes for
not hugging him um and it's yeah I'm
gonna get choked up just talking about
it um can you sort of talk about
shooting that you are gifted a couple
things as an actor one you're gifted a
screenplay where it's all there on the
page and you know that your job is just
so much easier because it's all already
there for you but two you're then
gifted to be in a scene with
someone like Andrew and who someone of
Andrew's caliber where you as much as I
was willing to love Andrew before we
even started I didn't know Andrew I I
don't know what he's like I don't know
what his process is like but getting
onto a set with him and seeing how he's
and and he touched upon it very briefly
before which is he's doing an incredibly
complex thing where he's straddling
these Two Worlds where he's a trapped
adult man and he's a trapped
child and he has to be doing both of
these things in this scene which is
incredibly
complex um so the scene is easy when you
have someone like Andrew opposite you
because he's doing things that are
surprising
you that are breaking your heart
genuinely um and then all you need to do
is uh just be open and react to that and
what a pleasure to to work with someone
like like Andrew genuinely sorry I know
you're here and I'm your
dad I know it's really hard to come on
he's no slouch himself but but what was
it like for you I I want you know thank
you thank you that's so lovely but we we
those scenes are incredibly um I can't
still watch I can't watch the film
without without being affected but by
but but by that scene uh particularly I
think I think what's so beautiful about
it is the is the tenderness of of of
Jim's performance and the tenderness of
the of the of the writing as well
because I do like I think sometimes in
coming out Stories the the the maternal
character is usually the one that's
perhaps the one who's the more benign
character and not that not that it's
ever kind of completely binary but I
like the idea that he sort of
understands him in some way a little bit
more he sees him in some way um but th
those those ideas where someone is
saying I didn't come into your room
because I I I think I might have been
one of those people who would have
bullied you too was so brutal and how to
be able to um make that scene and make
though that storyline successful is
because that brutality exists within
families and that sort of brutal honesty
exists but it also coexists with with
real love and I think that's an awful
lot of queer stories I think aren't um
coming out story certainly aren't um
perhaps as Extreme as as many people
experience that there's um
you know as I say this it's it's not
it's not full embraced acceptance or nor
is it um outright rejection it's
somewhere in between and that's thorny
and I think that happens not just in in
queer families but in all our families
and I think that's what's very I think
that's what pierces the heart hearts of
the audiences I just learned this today
did you you shot this in your childhood
home yes I shot it in my house the film
is about vulnerability perhaps more than
anything else and how it's okay to be
vulnerable and if you are vulnerable it
allows you to know people better and
them to know you better so I wanted to
be quite vulnerable as I was making it I
suppose and so it was one of the choices
was to go back to this house and
decorate it like it used to be when I
was a kid and a scene like that scene
between the two of them it wasn't the
easiest day you know to shoot you know
that's my old front room and you know
Jamie's quite a lot like my dad and you
know so there's a lot of like uh stuff
going on in in in that scene but I don't
know I feel like it helped the process
hugely um because you know I I'm asking
the cast to be uh vulnerable and expose
themselves and be intimate and put their
own lives into a story like this you
know so I want to do the same thing at
the same time and you hope you kind of
come to some common ground I'd never do
it again though
really maybe I should ask Sarah from
from a produc orial standpoint when he
says I want to shoot my child home then
you have to go talk to the people who
live there I presume or they were really
up for it though weren't they I mean we
did knock a wall down I I mean we did
their electrics so they were very happy
they yeah they'd only been one other PE
one other person that lived there off
since you'd left right yeah it's kind of
extraordinary it added a a real sense of
authenticity it made me think I cannot
act in this you know what I'm saying
like I just don't want to act you want
to be unadorned and we all we're all
going to create this recreate this this
thing together I just think it was such
an extraordinarily um Brave thing to do
on Andrew's behalf I want to ask because
I do know your actors and it's acting
but sometimes your body doesn't know the
difference when you're putting it
through you know these emotionally
taxing scenes and and really trauma um
do you have a way to sort of take care
of yourself and you as well as a
filmmaker I got exmo again which I
hadn't had since I was a kid e you know
like yeah like dermatitis being in the
house it suddenly all started coming up
again I'm like oh my God this is weird
maybe it's the house that's what I
thought was I just allergic to the house
but I don't think it was the house but
it you know it was it you know the look
you asking a lot from actors is a lot I
mean it was an emotional shoot for us to
do um but uh you know you take care of
yourself you know you know we were all
very you know it it was a really
enjoyable experience as well I wouldn't
say we're you know I think all of us
quite like sets to be quite light and
friendly and comfortable and you don't
want to feel like they're serious if
they're too serious I think it just
drains life from every scene when you're
doing something like that that's so uh
authentic that's your your challenge and
it was it is a genuine privilege to be
able to do something like that so even
if it's difficult and you're exhausted
again the generosity of Andrew was we
for for me just playing playing this
sort of character who was in all the
scenes we shot all the stuff with Jamie
and Clare first so uh it was
incredibly that was a very tough few
weeks because there was a lot of very
difficult scenes and then we had to say
goodbye I remember when Jamie was going
it was awful and was really but then so
you felt like you had a sort of uh a
parted history so then going into those
scenes with Paul where you were falling
in love and you were playing light
lightness and connection was just just
just completely wonderful and you felt
that you had had a life and you know
that that's all just about consideration
and it was a it was a it was a a real
vulnerable process but a real joyful one
and um I think that I do think that
shows on on the screen yeah um again I
want to remind everyone this is this
such a special movie please spread the
word I want to thank you for being a
great audience and again congratulations
thank you so much for being here thank
you so much every thank you so much
thanks